hi i'm maria i'm a tasty producer today
i've been challenged to take a common
food and make it fancy but first we have
some fancy news we got new merch this is
my lady now she's always with me if you
like it check out link in description
let's see what i'm making fancy today
chef boyardee beef ravioli so it's
ravioli in a can i like raviori in
general but i'm very skeptical canned
ravioli i know he's a real chef let's
check this out
smell like tomato soup definitely
factory made turns out it's like one
dollar
it's amazing and also
suspicious let's dissect this
the sauce is a little runny we have two
components ravioli and sauce and i have
to use both i feel like this is a
complete meal so it's difficult to make
something else from it i'm a little bit
nervous it might be a most challenging
ingredient
i have to think about this but i like
the challenge i'm excited to make it
fancy
all right here's what i got basil piano
tomato butter eggplant mozzarella cheese
parmesan cheese shallow pine nuts eggs
and garlic from the pantry i got flour
panko olive oil and salt okay let's get
started
make it fancy
right so the first step i'm going to
separate ravioli and
okay i cannot
open
mom
thanks
i think this is my
new
new year's resolution able to open a
camp by myself one of our crew members
told me there is always one ravioli
stuck in a can and that was true i'm
using mesh soup so we can separate
ravioli and sauce i set this aside means
shallow
shallow is milder than onion so i think
it will kind of support flavor like a
best supporting actress and shalom is
much smaller than onion so if i want to
use onion i will just use half but for
shallow you can use whole shallot i set
this aside use two cloves of garlic and
i'm going to mix it add one tablespoon
of oil
medium heat
add shallots saute until translucent add
garlic
while it's sauteing i'm going to open a
can tomato adding it to the pot add chef
boyardee sauce and i'm adding 5 tbsp of
butter so i'm adding butter to balance
it out with sweetness of the chef
boyardee sauce
and it kind of gives a nice rich flavor
and visually it's gonna add velvety
consistency add about like eight basil
leaves so you want to kind of simmer and
start
so the tomato chunks will breaks down
add salt you know you want to bring this
to a boil bring down the heat to low and
simmer about 20 minutes or until
thickened and we are moving on to next
step we have two eggplants i'm gonna
slice like half inch
eggplant is one of my favorite
vegetables whenever i see eggplant in
the menu i have to order eggplant is one
of the polarizing
ingredients but i love it really you got
your lady
yes this is my lady still shop
so one of
my instagram followers tagged me and she
took her lady to a spa and it was a
skate and she was sharpening it so
everyone has their own lady who is your
lady that was komasha like what's in
your wallet
drizzle olive oil you kinda wanna do
generously and i feel like eggplant it's
like a sponge it will absorb a lot of
oil that makes it delicious
so maybe i like oil not the eggplant
flip it i'm kind of eyeballing but i
want to core eggplant pretty well i'm
using a lot maybe this is my new alcohol
olive oil
season with salt the other side
so also i'm eyeballing but i feel like
big pinch per eggplant eggplant is
pretty bland flavor by itself so you
also want to sew it generously cook this
eggplant in the oven at 425 fahrenheit
25 to 30 minutes until it's golden brown
and soft so we have parmesan reginal
grated i will need quarter cup use it
later two tablespoons of pine nuts one
clove of garlic process until finely
chopped and you want to add basil two
cups the reason you do it if you pulse
pine nuts and garlic together with basil
that will make basil color look a little
bit brown 3 4 cup of olive oil drizzle
oil while you're housing
add some cheese and at this point you
just like pulse a couple times
okay my pesto is done put them in a bowl
it's nice pretty green color smells nice
this is looking good i'm moving on to
the next step i have flour egg wash and
panko we have strained ravioli stretch
them in flour
it's weird
it's like slippery if it's too much you
can just like blush it off so you want
to fully cover
with egg wash so you can coat with panko
so my oil is heating to 350. i'm going
to fry four at the time so oil
temperature doesn't go down this is
already cooked so you don't need to
worry about inner temperature so you
just want to fry until it's golden brown
it's nice color
okay we are going to core rest of the
ravioli fry it and moving on to the next
step eggplant is nicely baked and i have
finished the tomato sauce here cut some
mozzarella cheese here kind of slicing
about quarter inch it's very firm you
kind of need strings put baked eggplant
and tomato sauce ravioli
mozzarella cheese parmesan cheese put
another piece of eggplant and put tomato
sauce fried ravioli so cheese
more palm jeans and i'm going to keep
building this we don't have alcohol so
we are doing double cheese i
think we can go farther but i don't want
to risk it okay so i'm going to bake
this in the oven for 25 fahrenheit about
10 minutes until this mozzarella cheese
is melted and nice okay so cheese is
nice and melty and i'm going to finish
this plate put a little bit of sauce in
the bottom so it kind of become like a
glue
put the stock on top put a little bit of
pesto
a little bit of parmesan cheese
garnish with basil
and we are done
[Music]
chef boyardee eggplant parmesan stock
it's very fancy
[Music]
so due to the popular demand my fellow
tasty producer chris is back thank you
for having me back here and make it
fancy yeah thank you for coming back
okay so really i actually have a
surprise for you all right
i'm wearing a never ever seen before
make it fancy merch oh my god do you
want to see it yes all right
oh my god it's so cute
right it's a rainbow
chris i said it before but you're a very
well dressed man and looks very fancy
thank you what do you think i made
ah that's a really good question it
looks beautiful it looks beautiful nice
garnish
on top that's basil
i'm not mistaking do you wanna dig in
yes i do want to dig in i think this is
what you made fancy oh
yes
so let's see what this is yeah
i feel like my my stomach is fancy now
that's that's how it feels i'm
internally fancy i just don't know what
to say okay canned ravioli wow
love it i have a nickname for you he's a
gentle giant
gentle giant yeah what's the inspiration
behind that name
and the gentle and yeah
make it fancy it's my first time on make
it fantastic yeah welcome betsy oh my
gosh so happy to be here what do you
think i made well i see eggplant
i have a feeling that whatever you made
fancy is this like fried thing yeah on
the top a rice ball
do you want a cracker
buddy a crab cake well you to find out
okay this is really good number one is
it a ravioli oh my gosh i did chef
boyardee
so you had it before i definitely grew
up on like chef boyardee and like
spaghettios chef boyardee needs to take
some tips from chef rye i'll tell you
that
high five all right betsy so
you've seen this show before right do
you want to practice first
make it fancy
[Music]
you